there's more weather issues out there
every county in Oklahoma is under a
state of emergency because of flooding
evacuations are in effect along the
Arkansas River with high water straining
aging dams and levees Manuel Bojorquez
is in Fort Smith Arkansas where the
water is reaching historic levels Manuel
how high is that water and are the
levees holding up oh good morning around
Fort Smith the levees are holding up for
now but that's not stopping the river
from spilling over into neighborhoods
like this one one neighbor you're about
to meet Jason ball was nice enough to
let us use his boat this morning so we
could get closer to homes like that one
where you can see the water is close to
the roofline the river is at 40 feet
that is a record and it with rain in the
forecast it's only expected to rise it's
a mission against rising waters National
Guard helicopter swooped in yesterday
dropping five thousand pound sandbags to
reinforce strained levees some along the
river took matters into their own hands
building makeshift barriers around their
homes floodwaters from the swollen
Arkansas River are threatening thousands
of people from Kansas to Louisiana where
the Mississippi River is now beginning
to flood hundreds of people in Sand
Springs Oklahoma had to evacuate when
the river swallowed parts of that
community and a nearby Tulsa more than
1.2 million people are being warned that
water released from nearby keystone dam
could threaten levees built in the 1940s
here in Fort Smith the levees are
holding up for now but waters are
creeping into neighborhoods like this
one in Riverland Terrace which can only
be accessed by boat all the houses that
are in the neighborhood are pretty much
have water in them Jason Voss home is
safe on higher ground so he's using his
boat to help neighbors what's been the
reaction from people that you're helping
they asked could I take them in the boat
and see their house and we've offered
you no storage at our house Bill Walker
has lived here about 35 years yes this
is the highest whatever baby
he hired contractors to build a wall to
try and keep the creeping floodwaters at
babe how are you feeling just watching
this water come on well it's a bad
feeling but there's you know thousands
of people just like my wife and I up and
down the Arkansas River that are you
know they've already had to evacuate so
our prayers go out to me the river is
expected to crest today but it's not
expected to go down significantly for
several days and not expect it to return
to its normal level possibly for several
weeks so this contaminated water with
hazards like poisonous snakes it's gonna
be around for a while
Gayle boy thank you again to jason ball
for letting you use a boat it came in
very handy for you today man well thank
you so much